des canalisations d'eau de 40 ans d'â
usé et fissuré des branchements
d'origine parfois effectués à la vavite
et des fite et des inondations chez les
particuliers en cas de fortes pluie le
syndicat intercommunal d'assaainissement
de la Courance intervient actuellement
sur les communes de coignère et de morpa
afin de mettre le réseau aux normes et
rajeunir les canalisations nous
intervenons chez les particuliers qui
ont des problèmes de conformité de
raccordement c'est-à-dire dont les EAU
usées se ver dans le réseau d'eau
pluvial ou inversement les eaux
pluviales ce qui est moins grave mais
qui est quand même un peu gênant dans
les eaux pluviales des toit se déversent
dans le réseau d'eau usé la législation
française et notamment la loi sur l'eau
de 2006 impose désormais aux
particuliers aux entreprises la mise au
normes du réseau les concernants c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
maintenant les armes juridiques pour
obliger les les gens à à se mettre en
conformité les gens donc les
particuliers les entreprises et puis
d'autre part nous bénéficions
d'aide de subvention dès lors qu'il y a
un programme groupé l'Agence de l'Eau SC
Normandie et le Conseil Général des
iveline prennent à leur charge 75 % des
700000 € d'investissement 144
particuliers sont concernés par ces
travaux sur les deux communes à partir
de 2013 le sic procédera aux réparation
du réseau chez 77
entreprises